voodoo
April 19, 1973 Since
the landing unit of extraterrestrial lifeforms, which
was named from the moon, fell to the earth,
human beings have entered into a full-scale war with extraterrestrial lifeforms,
training up to a total population of billions
invaders from space  Beta
so-called as a species of extraterrestrial origin hostile to
humankind Humans develop tactical aircraft to counter it
July 1998
Data progresses to Japan and quickly conquers the
Chinese region of the ball species
August 15
Eventually the body and even Kyoto fell. The
battlefield
moved to eastern Japan. It
was useless today.
Akiyoshi Murata, who was ordered to take up the
post, Saotome Mado is Masa Iha Vol
.  Necessary to be a consort
aircraft I understand that I'm gonna guide you. Bah ah ah [Music] Third has been fortified from early on as a key point in the defense of the Sea of Japan.  In
addition, the 5 squadrons were left with most of their
troops pulled out by the dispatched troops. The
foundation was filled with newcomers a4
. I was also a
newcomer from Yokohama a week ago.
If
Niigata falls and the Gunma Nagano mountainous area falls into the hands of beta, the
entire Kanto plain will be within the range of the laser class
. Then
even Yokohama and Tokyo where you came will be in
danger of tactics.
If I had to stop it, my
former troops were also eager
to protect today. I know
that half of them didn't come back in the first sortie and
couldn't exceed 4-8 minutes
.
Be sure to
protect this country
[Music] No
request for evacuation has been issued to civilians. Although a forced deportation
order has been issued, I do not want to leave the place where I was born and raised.
And there are many people who do it. Besides, it is difficult to find a place to accept due to the turmoil of the short circuit in western Japan.
The limit of tactics is near
, so our department  The corps has the
possibility that the fortress defense unit including the tactical aircraft company will also go to support on the star of
the balloon, and
today's detection system has
been activated.  It
is seen that the company will be subdued the next morning in the middle of the milk
.
12 Maru 4 to 14
Margot First confirmation No. 1 If you have a Martin feeling, you will
get a good feeling 1 q Protect No. Complete work Reaction expansion
area af Accumulation to a San Baru
's monitoring enhancement Hurry to remove underwater noise Environmental
sensor accuracy
The report is from
the Imperial Navy 2nd Fleet Shinano, which is being introduced
.  1 wave
confirmation
Contact the beard Here before 3rd to 7th Shake me from the
hill Ready to shoot from the hill I
will not attract enough with that heart The
first tactical aircraft company will take the April system and understand that the
progress speed will not slow down
Well then, it's a good type 2 married to overseas
.
Forget it and get rid of it 1 a Tube
misalignment
Conversion Thin one and
absolutely protect the sub
2nd wave 3rd wave disappearance All spit out the
stand When 2 sets
, the
big Olympics is the
10th place lion  Shut up,
10 It's a
stable floor, and
I'm guilty of remembering the simulation
.
By the time d Medium response sortie It
seems that it is somehow turning against the expected force There is no tactical unit on the day of the month
The support of the U.S. military is still in the air
The 7th fleet is still moored off the coast of Yamagata
I'm done, prepare for the next sortie. It's been over
16 to 4-8 minutes since the sortie.
Thank
you.
bj It's
a country where the seaside is
clogged up from 6 points up to 56. It
seems to be the same as the dropout.
There
must have been no report of the dropout of the terrorist
auto-class,
which seems to be an invasion from the continent.
I don't know the friendship again, but I'm not in a situation where I'm in a battle with the beta army
. It's a good way. I haven't received
any response yet
.
I'm
gonna do it
after
one throw photo 9 I think it's softly goo This guy is on the 4th floor Congestion car port Suddenly at 36mm, the teeth
are standing
120 Wait carefully to see 0
dai
11 yen
eme
me
tan
Tableware  Tomo Brake Wide talks about
landing point and 4 and 9 plays are post-arrested New pose
9 Great 10 people
Calm down as it is
Yeah Yeah Yeah tee
car
[Music]
wh Yeah Yeah Yeah
However, I don't want to wear it.
No,
this cafe is
dee
leisure data. Me
Afternoon station is
broken
uh
re
jantak dj is a
ghost Ito Naka entering
village company
tee
q It's a
Spanish or fluttering coastal area with a radar stationed
Rin
4  It's a sudden dropout. Is it
finally here? It's a
picture book even if the remaining strength of the tactical aircraft squadron is considerable.
The damage is enormous, and the
remote team will be the first Gamba.
0 Once again, life is
up to high school.
The 2nd fleet, which is not in the
fleet
even though it's
a year.
Stop shooting.  If you can't fight, it's
just a hindrance.
Join the middle and large dungeon
and carry out the order. The
water doesn't go.
[Music]
The 2nd fleet has communicated to the command center to evacuate to Ryotsu Port
.
Just tell me if you're an
admiral or
thank you  But
the wonder of me consists of four heads that come out a little more
.
It
will be before the masterpiece of good music comes.
Tadashi Tadashi I
wonder if the mission has been done.
Currently, the transport boat is accommodating civilians
. It seems that we will head there as soon as confirmation is obtained.
Don't lose 5 as a military man 5 Don't
look away from this miserable reality
Live
adan
[Music]
Prescription
doesn't come
4 Vol
.
Nah
[music]
is
playing taroo
[music]
only The cause of the main ship is urgently 0
Command personnel are currently inmates The fortress
command visit is not included in any one of
Nishimura's  Contrast
Only if you thank
Kankun for a little
[Music]
There are sequel symptoms, but there is no trauma. It's
an advanced bread miracle.
[Music] A
miracle may be possible.
The
cumulative number of dead and missing
is about 36 million in the entire Japanese empire,
and the 21st number,
Sado Island 5, was built on Sado Island.
[Music]